to be honest my man
I think it's a cry for help who do you
think sneakers lost there's some there's
something going on if you guys aren't
aware sneakers upset guns were pulled uh
fights were issued a call for helps were
sent out for discords asking for
information yes and dirt on Apple and
preach yes a lot of stuff happened he's
uh he's he's spiraling a little bit but
anyways why don't we uh play the video
the dirt was was was that since I've
been preaching oh yeah oh yeah I'm so
sick of having preached send me clips
and all the memes of all the [__]
[__] they've said uh he said he started
talking about you know he's talking
about you guys can see it on the screen
but uh why don't we play and I'll be
honestly I'm just watching this all from
afar you know feeling like Nostradamus a
little bit you know predicting the
downfall watching The Descent listen my
dude I already told you numerous times
numerous time I told you that [__] I
told you
you're a wizard Abba to be fair some
wizard [__] this was a wizard [__] no
target I saw sneaker driving on the
highway with his feet on the steering
wheel driving with his feet on the
steering wheel and his girl was [__]
in the back
I could just see sneako in a retirement
home for like War veterans and then like
all the old people just twitched like
Iraq Iraq Vietnam and the sequel's just
like [__] [__]
you started [__] with me by insulting me
and my girlfriend out of nowhere so
naturally I responded by making fun of
you in return and showcasing the reasons
why I don't respect you but
unfortunately I failed to calculate just
how much of a sensitive [__] loser
you are because this hurt your feelings
to such a high degree it's become like
an Armageddon in your brain three months
you have continued to melt down about
this the day after I posted my response
he went on stream and had a huge
unhinged tantrum and meltdown about the
whole thing and then he sent some of his
viewers over so I was anybody wants a
gun please keep your [__] finger off
the trigger all this like stupid beef
aside like if you own a gun be smart
about how you handle it because seeing
how stupid he's behaving right here in
this video I wouldn't be surprised if
there's one actually loaded inside you
know so like if you if you're doing that
and you pop off you might kill the
neighbors below you above you and you
catching one of the dumbest manslaughter
charges possible so I was joking with
them saying like oh you guys must have
just stopped the cuties watch party over
there it's Nico stream right welcome Cox
that kind of [__] and it got really
under his skin in a big way so he
started dancing around with the gun and
threatening to come shoot me so he kept
saying oh you're in Tampa right I'll
come see you waving his gun around and
dancing
you want to watch my Clips watch my
clips
watch my clips
you wanna oh you want me to watch your
Clips watch my clips
he's the only clip Sunrise you are what
is it with them in self snitching
what's up with that yeah I'm gonna come
to your house and then wave a gun and
then film it and broadcast it
then you're gonna blame the Matrix
that's what boggles the mind you're
gonna blame the Matrix
Matrix did
from off the Matrix and then you try to
go back to the Matrix
and then you snitch on yourself and then
you're gonna blame the Matrix goddamn
red pillows really be like
The Matrix
[__] I just watch it The Matrix
that's you and I'm sorry to be that guy
this is like the grammar police of guns
but he's a [__] imbecile you absolute
buffoon what you have there is not Clips
these are mags they're mags not Clips
you absolute [__] dummy the same way
that this is also a MAG they're all mags
stop saying Clips you look [__]
stupid here Loki
I'm in Tampa stay in my ground and you
will come through and I will show you
mags instead of Clips without you no we
in here waiting for you no he's been
asking specifically moist uh to have a
boxing match this guy wanted to be a
comedian he then gets mad because
Charlie says he's buffer than sneako so
sneako being the brave man that he is
wants to fight five foot six Charlie I'm
not calling him small I'm saying he has
no muscles yeah but hit the gym Andrew
Tate preaches getting a better physique
you really body watching right now
you're body shaming but you can't fight
[__] chat I don't wanna I'm not
reacting to a stream this guy's pissed
me off and you can tell him this I want
to meet him in person Monica I just want
to take your BUN and a fist
and then slam it down like I'm mashing
butter your dumb mouth that I wanna
that it's something and smash her head
up and down like I'm mashing butter onto
my crotch Angela Wallace you got me
feeling some type of way but rainbow wow
those glasses this one little bit I
challenge you you want to box me bro
let's do a 1v1 boxing match you say I
belong to the streets yeah I belong to
the streets we could walk this out on
the street so we can do it in the ring
bro let's box you fat lying piece of
[__] I would beat the [__] out of you
Ethan Klein if you said that about me
you lie to my name to my face let's get
in the ring stop talking [__] about me
and let's box and then finally when
Brandon Buckingham is down to meet snico
he's there to box them they're both
similar sizes mind you there's Brandon
Buckingham said he wanted to run a train
on sneakers girl sneaker would now
rather just sit at home and tell jokes
behind his computer I'd rather just I'd
rather sit at home and deal at a camera
tell jokes than you know risk my manhood
falling flat for Branding Brandon
Buckingham you know if I lose the fight
so now it's suddenly cool to just stay
at home and keep it all online that's
cause you know you might lose
people are quick to call out people to
fight
when they think they're gonna win
and that's what I think happened with
our people fresh and Fit I don't want to
bring that back but that's what happened
when they challenge me because they
think I'm fat
because of the way we feel they think
I'm fat
most of y'all think I'm fat sometimes
you send me some fan uh pictures and fan
uh Arts that you sent me and you depict
me I'm fat I don't take no offense to
that I don't care I like the fan art
it's pretty good
and when you did that and I said I
accept you got a little oh what's going
on why would he do that huh and then
people of our fam starts that's what I
think happened started to go in this DM
and be like yo this guy is a bouncer and
he does martial arts you might not want
to do that yeah I'm pretty sure after
they challenged you you offered to fight
both of them back to back yes I did
right they was talking crazy you offered
to fight both of them back to back and
what did it happening we actually
offered to pay them to show up and not
and it wouldn't be on YouTube not even
on a clout thing no no cameras nothing
it was a one-on-one thing not even to
put out there you understand what I'm
saying you get me I'm not here to brag
or whatever what not but fighting one
person and fighting another person is
something that I had to do numerous
times in my life not because I wanted to
because that was my job a lot of these
people are going to challenge people
that they know they can they they think
they can beat they think because you end
up watching these people fight here's
the thing if you've ever been in enough
street fights you know that's just not
something to play with nobody knows how
to fight like take some classes and then
you realize that you don't know [__]
about [__] people that train are
generally the most humble when it comes
to violence because they understand it's
ramifications and if they receive the
training they also understand it comes
with responsibility you're not supposed
to be out here talking crazy to
civilians and trying to fight them all
the time yeah and a lot of people when
they train fight the first thing that
they tell you in a fight the first thing
that you can do is
flee in a self-defense situation
if you are a big monster human and you
want to fight me
and you square off with me guess what
I'm gonna do
run away
um
because I don't want I don't want to get
involved even if I see skinny little Lex
out on the street and you start yelling
at me and saying you want to fight me I
don't want to fight you I don't it
doesn't matter I don't I don't care if I
can beat you or not what if you stab me
what if you sue me after I get done
throwing you onto the concrete there's a
million bad things that can happen and
almost nothing good my first
self-defense is my feet to get away from
you leave that's the first move it's
just because they challenge people I see
this thing happen a lot I'll fight you
fast that's you not eating being able to
control your ego you know it's funny
that these red pill dudes want to talk
about discipline and all this other
stuff they can't control their emotions
you know like sequel want to call
himself a comedian anytime people joke
on his name all of a sudden he wants to
pull out guns and fight this dude is a
clown trying to be out here telling I
can lead men again watch the pattern you
you notice this because if you've ever
been someone who followed great leaders
they don't look like these guys they
don't behave the way that they do well I
know why because if you follow these
kinds of men in life it would lead to
your death if you had a commander or if
you had a leader who basically got hyper
emotional when insulted or let his ego
get in the way of making all the smart
decisions your unit's not gonna survive
and so that's why when I listen to this
kind of guy I'm just like bro you're a
clown who's basically cosplaying as some
kind of
masculine leader but then every time
people poke they see there's a bunch of
chinks in your armor that's insecurity
I'm deeply afraid of somebody calling me
a [__] you're a [__] there I helped
you overcome your fear if that's all it
takes for you to start challenging
people to fights you're not ready to be
a man you're a boy if you get that
agency at the slightest provocation
you're not ready to protect a family
you guys understand that restraint is
oftentimes the biggest thing that you
can do to protect your loved ones you
know if somebody looks at your kid and
says oh whatever they say some you think
your job is to just go out there and
start punching in the face how are you
gonna protect your family when you're in
jail people getting stupid people how
are you gonna protect
anybody or provide for them when they're
going to be destitute or whatever
financial situation when you are in jail
stupid not even in jail on the moment
guys talking why I challenge a guy I'm
with my wife and kids I'm like yo wanna
do this wanna do it he decks me in the
mouth I'm out cold what happens to my
wife what if he has a weapon you know
like I'm not saying there's not a place
where you defend the people around you
absolutely that always comes in time and
place that that's the thing of course
but you got to also understand the
strength you got to do a bit of risk
assessment you got to be able to keep
your cool so the people around you can
stay safe that's what it means to be a
man not be you want to see my eclipse
and I'm just telling you all these red
pill dudes a lot of them start
self-exposing right they start
self-reporting they start self snitching
anytime you start to pressure them a
little bit why don't know why because
underneath whatever facade they put
online this Persona what you realize
that Underneath It All it's a soft
little boy who's inner nerd who got
bullied has never actually outgrown that
certainly not one of those good people
matter of fact I'm straight up kind of
an [__] I'm an extremely
self-involved insecure and
overcompensated wannabe that constantly
speaks about things I barely know about
and and when people speak to me I don't
listen I just wait for my own turn to
speak
all right at least you know bro
hey look people want to have sympathy
for him all this other stuff oh I feel
bad he's a young man you know give him
time on I question does he even show a
modicum of respect or sympathy for
others going through any kind of
struggle anybody this is D'Angelo
Wallace who took a break from YouTube
after going through some stuff I haven't
found a way around it
um oh no oh God
I searched for ways around it I I do
everything I'm supposed to do like you
know therapy and taking care of myself
and all of that stuff but the truth is I
have
really severe anxiety and depression oh
yeah and it often leads to
your Aviation oh no um yeah
maybe stop thinking about that [__]
right you know matter of fact [__] your
mental health your problems are so easy
I'm set get the [__] over it this is a
perfect example of somebody who needs to
get the [__] up over it get over it
get over it whoa that was his response
get the [__] over it
sneak I think it's time for you to get
the [__] over the fact that you're a
cook
get over it you are a cook it's okay
it's what you are
no matter how much you cosplay as some
conservative red pillar who's found God
and knows all those [__] meanwhile
you're still having all the premarital
sex drugs and booze and all the kind of
Hedonism you want so you think all guys
cheat every guy cheats every guy wants
to cheat at least every no guy is
naturally monogamous we just like
variety it's okay you're a cuck
my God that's what everyone's always
going to see you as even though you hate
that moment even though that's what
you're gonna be seeing that that's what
you are you need to go to some therapy
and get over it have some
self-acceptance the only reason people
can use this against you this
aggressively is because they know it
makes you uncomfortable and you're
ashamed personally I don't care that
you're a cook nope I don't even give a
[__] that you're doing all this weird
stuff sexually that's your life go do
that I just think it's funny how
sensitive you get about it when people
mock you for it meanwhile you want to
judge everyone else based off of these
judeo-christian values that you yourself
don't live by the hypocrisy is what I'm
laughing at I don't care that a man
sleeps with another man what I think is
hilarious is when you're a pastor who
does anti-gay sermons and then behind
closed doors you taking dick from Tyrone
every other Sunday like the miles of
dick that you took in your ass I don't
want to walk them
right you want to talk about everyone
else's sexual activities and how not
straight these guys are meanwhile you
had to do tickling your balls while you
were smashing a girl that's pretty sense
to me I mean I mean what other straight
guy has so many half-naked photos of
himself he was jerking off in front of a
male photographer laying next to another
man's ass as a kid he wore his sister's
dress did I mention he was touching his
pener in front of a male photographer
and so while I'm like hitting it from
the back he lays down on the floor and
starts licking her think about the
logistics like his head is like under
it's like six inches like his eyebrows
are like tickling the bottom I'm not
gonna lie the stuff that's in this video
is probably some of the gay [__] I've
ever seen a dude potentially do most of
these guys online who do this stuff on
the red pill are over compensating
for some [__] yeah they won't be like oh
what happened I think you're gay what
bro you got picture of you laying in bed
with another man and you got a picture
of you kissing another dude like y'all
really can't see much and I don't care
that you have these things I just think
it's hilarious when people throw stones
from glass houses you try to call out
everybody but that's what you do yeah
that's that's what you do you have a
problem you guys are the Derrick
Jacksons of the South that's what you
are talking one [__] and putting out
other people for the same [__] that you
do we do not care that you do all those
things I don't care that you go out with
ass workers or people or sugar babies or
this and that or Instagram models that's
you but when you put down other people
and you look at other people you're
really talking about yourself you're
really talking about yourself he said
multiple times that he wants to be the
next Andrew Tate I'm trying to be that I
want to be the top G one day when the
Tates got banned off YouTube Tristan
passed the torch to sneakum and he
completely creamed himself I'm gonna
continue living the life so stinko young
man
if I discipline
disappear torch to you keep spreading
the message while it's still relevant to
talk Chris and Tates that he passed me
the torch it's not gonna be easy but
what you really want is a good man to
[__]
yeah come here shut the [__] up with
your feminism shut up shut up Chad Chad
shut the [__] up yeah yes yeah yeah
that's what you need you need that do I
feel bad for this guy absolutely
absolutely not no I don't feel bad for
none of these dudes these guys are
poison yup they're a poison in society
pretty much so yeah if people want to
exercise them for the internet I got no
problem get the filth out that's what I
think anything else you want to say no